l'ordre du jour rappelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée du projet de loi portant
transposition de la corde nationale
interprofessionnelle relatif au partage
de la valeur au sein de l'entreprise
la parole est à Monsieur Olivier du
socle ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion
[Applaudissements]
de la commission des affaires sociales
sur le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs
les députés au mois de septembre dernier
j'ai saisi les partenaires sociaux en
leur demandant d'ouvrir une négociation
interprofessionnelle autour du partage
de la valeur dans les entreprises
cette négociation cette discussion a
abouti par un accord majoritaire qui
était signé le 10 février dernier 10
février 2023 portant justement partage
amélioration des partages de la valeur
dans les entreprises le gouvernement
nord de l'ouverture de cette discussion
entre partenaires sociaux c'était
engagée à transcrire fidèlement l'accord
si l'accord devait intervenir c'est ce
que nous faisons avec ce projet de loi
nous le faisons avec la fierté de
présenter devant vous des mesures
concrètes pour valoriser le travail et
mieux associer les salariés aux
résultats de l'entreprise nous le
faisons avec ce projet de loi par ces
dispositions qui en réalité sont assez
conformes à ce que nous faisons depuis
2017 pour revaloriser le travail au
bénéfice du pouvoir d'achat des ménages
la loi pacte 2019 avait permis de
simplifier la mise en place d'accord
d'intéressement et de participation dans
les PME et plus récemment la loi portant
en mesure d'urgence pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat votez ici même en
juillet 2022 a permis de faciliter
davantage le recours à l'intéressement
dans les PME et d'instaurer une nouvelle
prime de partage de la valeur ce projet
de loi transposition permet d'aller plus
loin et il fait évoluer les obligations
de partage de la valeur des entreprises
au profit des salariés et ce à trois
égards au moins d'abord je vais
souligner l'importance qu'on voulait
donner les signataires de l'accord à la
question de la classification au sein
des branches les organisations doivent
en effet se réunir tous les 5 ans pour
examiner la nécessité de renégocier les
classifications dans le cadre des
conventions collectives en réalité et en
pratique l'ancien témoigne des grilles
révisés étaient d'environ 12 ans en 2021
c'est donc un frein à la dynamique des
salaires c'est un frein à la lisibilité
des progressions de carrière au sein des
branches qu'il fallait améliorer
c'est pourquoi à l'initiative des
partenaires sociaux le premier axe du
projet de loi consiste à créer une
obligation d'engager une négociation
d'ici le 31 décembre 2023 pour les
branches en vue de l'examen de la
nécessité de réviser les classifications
pour celles qui n'ont pas procédé à ces
examens depuis 5 ans c'est donc une
mesure concrète qui va permettre
d'améliorer les rémunérations de mieux
valoriser les parcours professionnels
des salariés et ce dans le contexte
d'inflation que nous connaissons ensuite
ce projet de loi permet de développer
les dispositifs existantes partage de la
valeur dans les petites et moyennes
entreprises en effet nous le savons
l'usage des dispositifs de partage de la
valeur est trop inégal et à l'avantage
des plus grandes entreprises ainsi 70%
des salariés des entreprises de plus de
100 salariés disposés d'un accès à un
dispositif de participation en 2020
quand 3% de ceux des entreprises de
moins de 9 salariés et 6% de ceux des
entreprises comptant entre 10 et 49
salariés
de fait les entreprises de moins de 50
salariés nous le savons aussi ne sont
pas soumises à l'obligation de mise en
place de la participation et donc avec
ce texte avec cet accord il s'agit
d'aller plus loin pour développer le
partage de la valeur dans ces mêmes
petites entreprises et ce avec quatre
dispositifs qui nous paraissent
essentiels d'abord le projet de loi
permet aux entreprises de moins de 50
salariés de négocier par accord de
branches ou d'entreprises des formules
dérogatoires à la formule légale de
participation la formule actuelle peut
constituer dans certains cas un franc
développement du partage de la valeur
dans ces entreprises et c'est donc une
souplesse de plus pour les plus petites
entreprises ce qui permettra de
faciliter la mise en place d'accords
par ailleurs et c'est le second point
pour généraliser les dispositifs de
partage de la valeur dans les petites
entreprises celles dont 11 à 50 salariés
devront mettre en place un tel
dispositif dès lors qu'elles auront dès
lors qu'elles auront réalisé un bénéfice
net fiscal positif supérieur à 1% de
l'archive d'affaires pendant 3 années
consécutives il y a en effet pas de
raison que les entreprises depuis plus
de 50 salariés doivent absolument mettre
en oeuvre une dispositif un dispositif
de partage de la valeur et passer de
moins de 50 salariés quand elles le
peuvent c'est donc un manque que le
projet de loi et le projet d'accord
propose de combler le troisième
dispositif pour aller plus loin pour les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés cette
fois consiste à dire qu'elles auront
jusqu'au 30 juin 2024 pour négocier des
conséquences en termes de partage de la
valeur de la réalisation de bénéfices
considérés comme exceptionnels
et enfin l'accord prévoit que
l'exonération fiscale applicable pour
les salariés dans la rémunération est
inférieure à trois SMIC sur la prime de
partage de la valeur soit prolongée
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 pour les
entreprises de moins de 5 ans de
salariés je le répète et vous le voyez
ce sont donc là des mesures concrètes
qui permettent de généraliser des
dispositifs de partage de la valeur aux
petites entreprises et ainsi de revenir
sur l'inégalité de fait qui existe entre
en la matière entre les salariés des
petites et des moyens et des grandes
entreprises pour les développer dans
toutes les entreprises quelle que soit
leur taille au-delà de ce premier aspect
de généralisation et de facilitation des
dispositifs de partage de la valeur ce
projet de loi crée aussi de nouveaux
outils pour aller plus loin mais aussi
rénover certains dispositifs existants
ainsi le projet de loi crée le plan de
partage de la valorisation de
l'entreprise c'est un plan d'une durée
de 3 ans mise en place par accord pour
l'ensemble des salariés ayant au moins
un ancienneté et il permet un salarié de
bénéficier d'une prime dans le cas où la
valeur de l'entreprise de l'entreprise a
augmenté sur les trois années de durée
du plan
c'est donc un outil innovant qui permet
d'intéresser financièrement les salariés
à la croissance de la valeur de
l'entreprise et ainsi de les fidéliser
de la même manière le projet de loi
facilite aussi l'utilisation de la prime
de partage de la valeur telle qu'elle
avait été créée en juillet 2022 par
exemple les entreprises pourront opérer
jusqu'à deux versements de la prime par
an au lieu d'un seul et la prime
pourrait être versée sur un plan
d'épargne salariale permettant ainsi aux
salariés de bénéficier d'une exonération
fiscale pour les sommes bloquées le
projet de loi prévoit aussi de manière
plus générale une série de
simplification et d'assouplissement avec
notamment la sécurisation du versement
d'avance par trimestre pour la
participation et l'intéressement
ce projet de loi enfin développe
l'actionnariat salarié puisqu'il prévoit
de rehausser le plafond global général
d'attribution d'actions gratuites de 10
à 15% du capital social pour les grandes
entreprises et les ETI et de 15 à 20% du
capital social pour les PME
pour terminer je souhaite souligner que
les avancées de ce projet de loi sont
issus d'une méthode claire voulu par le
gouvernement qui a été celle de confier
sa discussion en partenaire sociaux je
disais au début de mon propos j'ai
invité en septembre dernier les
partenaires sociaux engagés une
négociation nationale
interprofessionnelle pour améliorer les
dispositifs de partage de la valeur et
ce sur la base un document d'orientation
qui les invitaient à négocier pour d'une
part renforcer le partage de la valeur
en travail capital au sein des
entreprises mais aussi améliorer
l'association des salariés aux
performances de l'entreprise et donc ce
projet de loi est la traduction d'un
exercice de démocratie sociale au début
de cette discussion lorsque nous l'avons
même imaginé il nous avait été prédit un
échec assuré au moment même où d'autres
négociations importantes étaient menées
en parallèle et pourtant le dialogue
social a eu lieu c'est pas interrompu et
a permis d'aboutir à un accord avec cet
ami conclut le 10 février dernier signé
par les trois organisations patronales
représentatives représentatives pardon
le Medef la CPME et du 2p et par quatre
des cinq organisations syndicales
représentatives la CFDT la CFTC est faux
et la CFE-CGC je souhaite saluer devant
vous leur travail et leur esprit de
consensus c'est la preuve que le
dialogue social permet de construire des
solutions concrètes consensuelles au
bénéfice direct des Français sur des
sujets qui font l'objet d'une forte
attente
cette méthode c'est poursuite ici au
Parlement et je crois que en tout cas
j'espère que la démocratie parlementaire
sera conservée les équilibres de ce
texte issu de la démocratie sociale
je veux saluer les travaux qui ont été
déjà menés par vos rapports par en
particulier par votre apporteur lui
Marguerite mais aussi par d'autres
députés comme la député vassals dans le
cadre de la mission qu'ils avaient
rapporté tous les deux je vais aussi
souligner que ce texte tel qu'il a été
voté par votre commission des affaires
sociales démontre l'attachement des
députés à l'équilibre du texte donc au
respect de l'accord bien sûr et par
souci de cohérence le gouvernement
souhaite que l'équilibre du texte soit
conservés à l'occasion de cet examen en
séance cela ne signifie pas qu'il est
impossible de l'améliorer mais nous
souhaitons comme je l'ai dit en
commission que les signataires de
l'accord soient favorables aux
améliorations proposées c'est le sens de
notre méthode et la garantie du respect
de ce succès du dialogue social mais
aussi la garantie du respect de
l'engagement pris d'une transposition
intégrale et fidèle
vous le savez par ailleurs certaines
stipulations de la corne n'apparaissent
pas en tant que tel dans le projet de
loi comme ça a été justifié par certains
des partenaires sociaux signataires nous
avons considéré qu'il s'agissait de
mesures qui nécessite pas à disposition
législative car elles peuvent être
d'ordre réglementaires parfois de
l'ordre de la pratique ou bien
satisfaite par le droit je pense
notamment au principe de substitution
mais je salue aussi le dépôt par votre
apporteur d'amendements permettant je
crois de rétablir l'équilibre du texte
sans remettre en cause l'article l3312
du Code du travail qui arrête le
principe de substitution je pense aussi
à la question de la définition des
bénéfices exceptionnels sur ce point la
corne nationale prévoyait que la
définition du bénéfice exceptionnel
relevé de l'employeur
avec l'accord des partenaires sociaux
signataires nous avons proposé une
nouvelle rédaction qui propose de
renvoyer la définition des résultats
exceptionnels à une négociation et un
accord en entreprise
sur cette proposition même un risque
juridique ayant été soulevé le travail
doit se poursuivre et là aussi des
amendements étaient déposé en ce sens
avec cette volonté d'apporter des
précisions et ceux conformément à la vie
du Conseil d'État toujours dans le
respect de l'accord tel qu'il a été
signé
je constate aussi à ce stade de la
discussion que votre commission des
affaires sociales à l'initiatives du rap
du rapporteur et du groupe écologiste a
souhaité avancer à 2024 l'obligation de
mise en place d'un dispositif de partage
de la valeur pour les entreprises 11 à
50 salariés et le gouvernement ne
proposera pas de revenir cette
disposition à l'occasion de l'examen de
ce texte en conclusion mesdames et
messieurs les députés la volonté de
partager la valeur créée par les
entreprises réponds je crois à deux
demandes importantes des Français
d'abord œuvrer davantage pour le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés pour faire face à
l'inflation mais aussi répondre à une
forte demande de participation des
salariés dans la marge de leur
entreprise aspiration est valorisée
entendue qui rejoint d'ailleurs un désir
démocratie au travail par ce projet de
loi et grâce à cet accord nous nous
donnons les moyens de parvenir à ses
objectifs je crois que c'est une
proposition d'équilibre de concertation
mais aussi de solidarité accrue entre le
capital et le travail je vous invite
donc à adopter ce projet de loi et ainsi
être transposer fidèlement la corne
nationale interprofessionnelle du 10
février dernier relatif au partage de la
valeur
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Louis
Marguerite rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales et pour 10 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur pour avis mes chers
collègues je rêve d'un pays où on le se
parle à nouveau c'était ce que déclarait
le Premier ministre Michel Rocard à
cette même tribune le 29 juin 1988 lors
de son discours de politique générale le
10 février dernier vous l'avez bloqué
monsieur le ministre les organisations
syndicales et patronales sont parvenus à
un accord national interprofessionnel
ambitieux sur le partage de la valeur au
sein de l'entreprise peu y croyaient et
pourtant ils l'ont fait
de FO MDF en passant par la CFTC la CPME
la CFE-CGC l'UDP et la CFDT les
partenaires sociaux sont parvenus à
s'entendre à conclure cet accord
historique le projet de loi que j'ai
l'honneur de rapporter aujourd'hui
traduit en droit l'engagement du
gouvernement de transcrire fidèlement
l'accord des partenaires sociaux mes
chers collègues cet accord nous oblige
le 12 avril dernier à l'issue de
plusieurs mois d'audition nous avons
publié avec ma collègue du groupe
écologiste et Vasas un rapport
d'information portant sur l'évaluation
des outils sociaux et fiscaux de partage
de la valeur au sein des entreprises au
cours de notre travaux nous avons
additionné une quarantaine d'acteurs
organisation syndicale et patronale
économiste universitaire administration
publique ainsi que des associations et
les fédérations spécialisées dans les
outils de partage de la valeur
le constat que nous avons établi
ensemble et clair si la France est la
deuxième nation d'Europe en ce qui
concerne le partage de la valeur nous
avons encore des marges d'amélioration à
la matière nous pouvons être bien
classés au sein des nations européennes
mais ce n'est pas une raison pour ne pas
chercher à faire mieux à faire plus et à
faire encore davantage pour la
rémunération et les compléments de
rémunération de salariés en un sens
quand la richesse est créée qu'elle soit
encore mieux distribuées au sein de ceux
qui ont contribué à la créer c'est tout
le sens de la corps signé par les
partenaires sociaux et de sens de ce
projet de loi ce dialogue social cette
écoute ce respect des partenaires
sociaux ont été notre boussole pendant
les quatre mois de travail et les mois
qui ont suivi consacré à la préparation
de notre rapport d'information je serais
également à saluer mes collègues
grasiers américains et Dominique Pottier
pour la qualité de leur rapport qu'ils
ont rendu en décembre 2020 qui avaient
été déjà précurseurs ce dernier
préconisait déjà à l'époque un
élargissement de l'accès à la
participation grâce à ce projet de Loire
que j'espère que nous voterons largement
ce sera désormais chose faite
je vous souhaite à présent vous dire
quelques mots des principales
dispositions des articles du texte qui
transposent exhaustivement et fidèlement
la Cour nationale interprofessionnelle
conformément à l'engagement pris par le
Président de la République par la
première ministre et par le ministre
Olivier du socle le titre premier vise à
renforcer le dialogue social sur les
classifications l'article premier
prévoir en ce sens l'ouverture d'une
négociation sur la nécessité de réviser
les classifications avant le 31 décembre
de cette année dans les branches qui ne
se sont pas pliées à l'exercice depuis
plus de 5 ans l'article premier bus que
nous avons introduit au sein de la
commission des affaires sociales il y a
quelques jours impose aux branches
d'établir avant le 31 décembre de
l'année prochaine un bilan de leur
action en faveur de la promotion et de
l'amélioration de la mixité des métiers
le titre II rassemble toutes les
dispositions qui ont pour objet de
faciliter la généralisation des outils
de partage de la valeur
l'article 2 ouvre aux entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés qui ne sont pas
tenus d'appliquer un régime de
participation la possibilité de le faire
par accord en retenant une formule de
calcul de la réserve spéciale de
participation la SP dérogatoire à la
formule de droit commun qui permet
d'aboutir un résultat qui sera moins
favorable ou plus favorable pour les
salariés l'article 3 il est important il
fait obligation aux entreprises qui
emploient entre 11 et 49 salariés et
dont la situation économique le permet
celle qui ont trois années de suite des
résultats positifs permet d'instituer un
dispositif de partage de la valeur j'ai
souhaité avec ma collègue et Bassas que
cette obligation entre en vigueur un an
plus tôt que celui qui a été prévu et je
remercie les commissaires aux affaires
sociales d'avoir accédé à cette demande
les articles 2 et 3 auxquels la
Commission a apporté quelques
modifications pour qu'ils traduisent
mieux l'intention des partenaires
sociaux s'appliqueront pour une durée de
cinq ans à partir de la promulgation de
la loi
dispositif phare de cet accord est
transposé à l'article 5 c'est sans
conteste l'obligation de mieux partager
les résultats d'une en augmentation
exceptionnelle des bénéfices dans les
entreprises de 50 salariés et plus et
qui compte au moins délégué syndical ce
sont près de 8000 entreprises qui sont
potentiellement concernés par cette
mesure et cela va donc bien au-delà des
grands groupes et des très grands
groupes le dispositif initialement
envisagé par les partenaires sociaux
confiés au seul employeur le centre de
définir ce qu'est une augmentation
exceptionnelle des bénéfices face au
risque au risque d'incompétence négatif
du législateur le projet de loi entendu
confié à la négociation collective cette
mission et cette discussion toutefois
pour tenir compte des réserves émises
par le Conseil d'État les partenaires
sociaux se sont à nouveau réunis pour
proposer une définition qui je l'espère
recevra un soutien massif de notre
assemblée dans le prolongement de la loi
pouvoir d'achat l'article 6 complète
quant à lui le mécanisme de la prime de
partage de la valeur la PPV et proroge
jusqu'à fin 2026 sa exemple
exceptionnelle en soutien au pouvoir
d'achat du personnel des seules
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
c'est pour cette pour qui cet outil est
essentiel la PPV a déjà bénéficié en
2022 à 25% des salariés du secteur privé
pour inventant un montant de 4,4
milliards d'euros distribués
nous souhaitons renforcer cet outil en
l'inscrivant durablement dans le champ
du partage de la valeur en somme gardons
ceux qui fonctionnent et pérennisons-le
sans que cela ne constitue une
alternative à l'actionnariat salarié la
Henni consacre le principe de
l'Association des salariés à l'évolution
de la valorisation de leur entreprise
sur le temps long et non plus uniquement
sur les résultats annuels instituer à
l'article 7 le plan de partage est
valorisation d'entreprises permettra aux
salariés à l'issue d'une période de
trois ans de bénéficier d'une prime dont
le montant dépendra du taux de
progression de la valorisation au cours
de la période le titre 3 du projet de
loi contient quant à lui plusieurs
mesures de simplification je vais pas
toutes les citer par exemple à l'article
9 la possibilité de verser en cours
d'exercice des avances sur les sommes
dues au titre de l'intéressement de la
participation et par exemple à l'article
12 l'aménagement des conditions
d'ancienneté en matière d'intéressement
et de participation dans la branche du
travail contemporain
enfin le titre 4 est consacré au
développement de l'actionnariat salarié
afin d'en assurer la diffusion et de
renforcer son caractère collectif ou
nous sommes déjà en pointe en termes au
sein des pays européens mais nous
pouvons aller plus loin l'article 13
rehausse les plafonds de distribution
d'actions gratuites les fameuses saga en
particulier lorsque celle-ci bénéficie à
une majorité des salariés de
l'entreprise il introduit en outre une
faculté de rechargement des plafond
individuel d'attribution d'actions fixés
à 10% du capital social de l'entreprise
en ne tenant compte que des actions
détenues depuis moins de 7 ans enfin
l'article 14 renforce le rôle de
l'épargne salariale dans le financement
de l'économie verte et solidaire et
impose que soit proposé au moins un fond
supplémentaire répondant aux critères de
financement et de la transition
énergétique et écologique ou
d'investissement socialement responsable
c'est une des traductions de la uni
mes chers collègues nous allons débattre
ici de la plus grande loi de sur le
partage de la valeur depuis la création
par le général de Gaulle de
l'intéressement en 1959 et de la
participation oui ça vous fait rire mais
c'est le cas et de la participation en
1977 aujourd'hui nous allons écrire une
nouvelle page de l'histoire du partage
de la valeur après celle qui a été
ouverte au sortir de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale ce projet s'inscrit dans le
prolongement de l'action conduite depuis
2017 pour protéger le poids d'achat des
Français avec les ministres notamment
Bruno Le Maire et beaucoup d'autres
protéger les Français pendant la crise
du covid et pendant la crise
inflationniste de 2022 baissez les
impôts des Français de 52 milliards
d'euros entre 2017 et 2022 supprimer les
taxes d'habitation qui a rapporté 20
milliards d'euros de pouvoir d'achat aux
Français soit un gain de 750 euros par
foyer relever à 7500 euros le plafond
des heures supplémentaires défiscalisées
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues ce projet de loi ambitionne
d'améliorer encore davantage de pouvoir
d'achat des Français grâce à vous
gravons dans le marbre le loup la loi de
l'accord du 10 février conclu par les
syndicats et les patronats de
Montceau-les-Mines à Aubervilliers en
passant par Dijon Armentières sur arbre
Chalon-sur-Saône Hazebrouck buxier
Cayenne le peuple français nous regarde
du nord au sud de l'est à l'ouest dans
l'Hexagone comme un outre-mer il compte
sur nous mesdames et messieurs les
députés chers collègues voici un texte
sur lequel je vous appelle à tous nous
retrouver il y a un an les Françaises et
les Français nous ont demandé de
travailler ensemble c'est en votant ce
texte largement sans esprit partisan que
nous ferons honneur à la démocratie
sociale mes chers collègues votons pour
le dialogue social votons pour un
renouveau du partage de la valeur votons
pour une plus grande attractivité des
entreprises votons pour un meilleur
partage des bénéfices votons pour ce qui
est le fondement même de notre
République votons pour l'intérêt général
tous ensemble
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
rapporteur
j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde panot et
des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nupes une motion de rejet
préalable les déposer en application de
l'article 91 alinéa 5 du règlement la
parole est à Monsieur Mathias Tavel pour
une durée maximale de 15 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues commençons par
dissiper l'enfumage il y a quelques
instants monsieur le ministre et
gargarisé à cette tribune il a inventé
la démocratie sociale qui permet que ce
soit conclut des textes comme l'accord
national interprofessionnelle du 10
février dont traite ce projet de loi
mais enfin depuis la pension de retraite
à 1200 euros les Français savent bien
que cette cascade a été réalisée par un
professionnel du retournement de veste
et du mensonge
entendre monsieur dupe parlez de
démocratie sociale est aussi crédible
qu'entendre Gargantua affirmé qu'il se
lancerait dans un programme minceur
comme les ogres les dévoreurs de droits
sociaux ne sont jamais rassasiés en
effet Monsieur dussoft si vous étiez
sincèrement pour la démocratie sociale
et même pour la démocratie tout court
alors vous auriez laissé notre assemblée
rejeter ou abroger la réforme des
retraites c'est là le premier motif de
cette motion de rejet nous ne vous
laisserons pas tourner la page des
retraites en instrumentalisant ce texte
pour votre communication ce texte que
vous nous présentez et pour vous un
alibi un alibi de dialogue social un
alibi de pouvoir d'achat d'un
gouvernement qui n'a rien fait depuis un
an pour augmenter les salaires
c'est le second motif de cette motion de
rejet nous voulons dénoncer la censure
que vous pratiquez la hausse des
salaires est pour vous à travers ce
texte un débat interdit c'est pourtant
la question numéro 1 dans le pays du
motorisme man diesel à Saint-Nazaire
jusqu'à Disneyland du nettoyage
industriel comme chez atalian wises
jusqu'à Carrefour ou Grand Frais de
Vertbaudet à la fonction publique
partout les travailleurs réclament le
juste salaire et partout vous vous y
opposez alors oui nous affirmons ici que
la hausse des salaires est une
revendication totalement légitime c'est
une mesure d'urgence sociale quand les
prix alimentaires augmentent de
17%. c'est une question de justice quand
les profils et les marges des biens de
bien des industries explosent sur le dos
des consommateurs c'est une nécessité
économique quand le pays va vers la
récession c'est enfin indispensable du
point de vue écologique si l'on veut que
les Français puissent consommer mieux
soutenir la filière bio en difficulté
faire vivre les producteurs locaux
plutôt que le low cost mondialisé il y a
urgence il y a urgence car la prédation
du capital ne ralentit pas bien au
contraire voyez ses grands patrons qui
gagnent 1200 fois le salaire moyen de
leur entreprise comme Monsieur Carlos
Tavares PDG de Steel antis 4000 fois le
SMIC un SMIC mensuel toutes les deux
heures de quel droit cela est-il permis
sinon par la toute-puissance du capital
en disant la rémunération des PDG du CAC
40 a augmenté de 90% dans les 100 plus
grandes entreprises françaises entre
2011 et 2021 les versements aux
actionnaires ont augmenté de 57% alors
que ceux pour les salariés
n'augmentaient que de
22%. cette oligarchie vit au-dessus de
nos moyens nous l'avons vu encore
récemment chez Total en novembre la
direction et votre gouvernement refusait
la hausse de 10% pour les salariés
quelques semaines plus tard le PDG
s'augmentait lui de 23%
la France est aujourd'hui un paradis
pour millionnaire et actionnaire notre
pays est champion d'Europe du versement
de dividendes aux actionnaires champion
d'Europe mais comme le disait déjà
Victor Hugo c'est de l'enfer des pauvres
qui fait ce paradis des riches
en effet les salaires réels c'est-à-dire
une fois l'inflation prise en compte on
baissé l'an dernier et le travail ne
protège plus de la pauvreté puisque la
France compte 1,2 millions de
travailleurs pauvres voilà le bilan du
macronisme l'injustice à tous les étages
pire encore en 2019
45% des dividendes et rachat d'actions
par les 100 plus grandes entreprises
françaises auraient suffit à couvrir
leurs besoins d'investissement dans la
transition écologique alors oui les
dividendes sont climaticides les
actionnaires sont écocidaires voilà la
vérité
il y a au fond de votre texte une
contradiction flagrante entre le titre
et le contenu dans le titre il est
question de partage de la valeur dans
les articles il est question que de
partage du profit or la valeur créée ne
se résume pas au profit le profit n'est
rien d'autre que la valeur créée par les
salariés mais qui leur a été volé par un
salaire trop plus faible que la richesse
qu'ils ont créé par leur travail parler
ainsi de partage de la valeur pour
indiquer seulement le partage du profit
cette exclure d'emblée d'augmenter les
salaires
encore une fois la Cinquième République
et les choix du gouvernement corset
l'assemblée vous avez volontairement
choisi de restreindre le champ de ce
texte à la simple transposition de
l'accord du 10 février cela vous permet
d'écarter les amendements qui sont
éloignent même un tout petit peu ainsi
vous avez interdit de débattre des
questions suivantes augmenter le SMIC à
1600 euros il recevable indexer les
salaires sur l'inflation il recevable
encadrer les écarts de salaire de 1 à 20
dans une entreprise il recevable obliger
les branches à augmenter les bas
salaires pour éviter l'écrasement par le
SMIC il recevable revaloriser le salaire
minimum des apprentis irrecevables
conditionné les versements de dividendes
à des hausses de salaire ircevable
et il en va de même quand à notre
volonté de faire avancer l'égalité
salariale entre les hommes et les femmes
vous l'avez systématiquement empêché en
refusant de renforcer la rémunération
des heures complémentaires des salariés
à temps partiel de créer une commission
de contrôle salariés pour vérifier
l'égalité salariale dans les entreprises
d'imposer une prime obligatoire dans les
entreprises qui ne peuvent pas justifier
du respect de l'égalité voilà les
propositions que nous portons face au
refus obstiné du gouvernement de la
minorité présidentielle du rassemblement
national et du patronat d'augmenter les
salaires et de partager les richesses
au moment du débat sur les retraites
vous avez empêché l'Assemblée de voter
par brutalité vous avez défendu ainsi le
droit de veto du monarque présidentiel
contre les représentants du peuple
avec ce texte voici une nouvelle
invention de votre part à court
d'arguments vous inventez une autre il
recevabilité politique patronale
devrais-je dire vous prétextez de devoir
respecter l'accord et ne pas accepter
qu'on le modifie sans l'accord de tous
les signataires c'est-à-dire à vos yeux
essentiellement sans l'accord du
patronat maintenant vous inventez donc
le droit de veto du Medef sur le
Parlement
après l'irrecevabilité de l'article 40
sur les retraites pour les salaires vous
inventez l'irrecevabilité CAC 40 ou même
pourrait-on dire après le 49.3 en
quelque sorte le cac49.3
nous refusons cette nouvelle restriction
du pouvoir de notre assemblée
nous rappelons d'abord que toutes les
organisations syndicales n'ont pas signé
cet accord national interprofessionnel
nous rappelons aussi que le 15 juin
dernier toutes les organisations
syndicales à l'unanimité ont appelé par
tous les salariés à revendiquer négocier
se mobiliser pour gagner des
augmentations de salaire
preuve que si ce sujet n'est pas dans
l'accord du 10 février ni dans le projet
de loi ce n'est pas de la responsabilité
des syndicats c'est de votre
responsabilité monsieur le ministre qui
n'avait pas exigé dans votre lettre de
cadrage que ce sujet fasse partie de la
négociation c'est la responsabilité du
patronat qui a refusé qu'il en soit
question pour notre part nous sommes
donc pleinement légitimes à défendre ce
que réclame l'ensemble de l'Inter
syndicale unanime les hausses de salaire
d'une manière plus générale vous faites
mine d'oublier que cet accord n'est pas
la démocratie sociale la démocratie
suppose l'égalité or il n'y a pas
d'égalité entre salariés et patronat cet
accord est seulement l'expression d'un
rapport de force dans lequel le patronat
tient le stylo vous faites mine
d'oublier enfin qu'il ait du rôle du
Parlement de se prononcer sans se voir
cantonner aux miettes qu'on s'est débar
le Medef c'est même anticonstitutionnel
que de prétendre empêcher le Parlement
de se saisir pleinement
en effet l'article 34 de la Constitution
prévoit que la loi détermine les
principes fondamentaux du droit du
travail du droit syndical et de la
sécurité sociale c'est donc bien la loi
qui décide en la matière et notre
Assemblée a donc le droit et le devoir
d'examiner d'amander de compléter et si
besoin de rejeter les dispositions de
l'accord conclu les intérêts
particuliers qui ont conduit à la
signature d'un compromis ne sont pas
automatiquement l'intérêt général du
pays telle est la conception
républicaine de l'ordre public social à
laquelle nous sommes si profondément
attachés comme à la République sociale
elle-même et on l'espèce l'intérêt
général du pays c'est la hausse des
salaires et la préservation des recettes
de la sécurité sociale et ces deux
éléments sont menacés par votre texte
car ce texte repose sur une illusion
dangereuse pour les salariés
entendons-nous bien qu'une entreprise
distribue une partie de ses bénéfices à
ses salariés c'est bien la moindre des
choses mais c'est déjà possible tout
entreprises même la plus petite à la
possibilité de verser une prime
exceptionnelle
en revanche les niches sociales les
niches fiscales au profit des primes de
l'intéressement de la participation sont
de notre point de vue des pouces au
crime anti salaire et antisecus
c'est l'exemple de la prime Macron elle
a privé les salariés qui l'ont touché de
240 euros de hausse de salaire chacun
elle ne sert d'ailleurs qu'à ça car pour
le reste c'est un échec 70% des salariés
n'ont rien touché et ceux qui l'ont
touché quelque chose ont perçu bien peu
en tout cas bien loin des 6000 euros de
plafond relevé à grand renfort de
démagogie l'été dernier par votre
minorité et vous voulez encore continuer
dans cette voie autrement dit vous
voulez inviter les salariés à se serrer
la ceinture pour espérer percevoir une
petite partie du bénéfice que leur
travail gratuit aura constitué mais
après bien sûr que les actionnaires se
sont servis du plus gros morceau
ce n'est pas avec des primes qu'on
convainc un propriétaire de louer un
appartement ce n'est pas avec des primes
qu'on convainc un banquier de prêter
pour acheter un logement ou même une
voiture ce n'est pas avec des primes
qu'on ouvre des droits à l'assurance
chômage ou à l'Assurance retraite mais
avec des hausses de salaire
cette logique de désocialisation comme
vous l'appelez des rémunérations est une
arnaque une arnaque partagée d'ailleurs
entre macronistes et le pénis le mot
lui-même traduit l'horreur de la chose
Monsieur Macron comme l'extrême droite
au Rondo jeux ensuite devenir pleurer
sur une soi-disant décibilisation mais
la désocialisation c'est à dire
l'affaiblissement de la sécurité sociale
la défiscalisation c'est à dire la
pauvrissement de l'État et des services
publics sont au cœur de l'effondrement
néolibéral de nos sociétés de l'abandon
de chacun aux tous contre tous de ce que
nous nommons pour notre part la dissocié
vous versez des larmes de crocodile sur
le soi-disant déficit des retraites mais
vous présenter un projet de loi qui va
encore affaiblir la sécurité sociale par
des exonérations de cotisations selon la
Cour des comptes ces exonérations
représentent déjà plus de 2 milliards
d'euros chaque année de manque à gagner
pour la sécu sur l'intéressement la
participation et les primes et avec ce
texte comme avec les amendements de
certains députés macronistes vous voulez
encore renforcer les plans d'épargne par
capitalisation
il faut souligner aussi que ces primes
profitent davantage au salaire les plus
hauts qu'au plus mal payés davantage aux
cadres qu'aux ouvriers et employés
davantage aux hommes qu'aux femmes en
les encourageant aveuglément vous
encouragez peut-être à votre corps
défendant pour certains l'inégalité et
même l'injustice des rémunérations vous
avez d'ailleurs refusé en commission
tous les garde-fous que nous avions
proposé mais ce projet de loi ne menace
pas que les salaires il menace aussi les
dispositifs existants de partage du
profit la prime Macron décidé
unilatéralement par l'employeur risque
de cannibaliser l'intéressement qui
nécessite au moins un accord collectif
le plan de valorisation de l'entreprise
risque de vampiriser l'actionnariat
salarié en ayant au passage le droit de
vote des salariés ce texte va menacer
les maigres pouvoirs des salariés alors
qu'il faudrait faire tout l'inverse
jusqu'à leur confier la direction des
entreprises
enfin vous prétendez par ce texte lutter
contre une forme de salariat à deux
vitesses entre grands groupes et PME
mais si vous vouliez vraiment lutter
contre cela vous lutteriez contre la
sécession des ultra riches contre les
super profits contre les super
dividendes contre les super patrimoine
vous ne faites rien de tout cela si vous
vouliez vraiment aider les PME vous
créeriez la caisse de solidarité
inter-entreprise que nous proposons nous
plafonneriez les frais bancaires pour
les PME vous renforceriez les devoirs
des donneurs d'ordre à les garder
sous-traitants vous auriez voté avec
nous pour rétablir l'accès des PME au
tarifs réglementés de l'électricité au
lieu de vous y opposer et dans ce texte
vous auriez accepté les amendements de
la nupais ce qu'ils veulent s'attaquer à
l'évasion fiscale des grands groupes
alors voilà par ce texte vous affirmez
une fois de plus votre préférence
actionnariale et par notre motion de
rejet nous affirmons notre préférence
salariale notre priorité sociale par
cette motion de rejet nous refusons
votre autoritarisme et le droit de veto
du Medef sur les hausses de salaire nous
refusons un nouvel affaiblissement de la
sécurité sociale qui vous permettra de
venir ensuite exiger de nouveaux recules
en matière de retraite en matière de
chômage ou justifier de nouveaux des
remboursements comme vous le faites sur
les soins dentaires et peut-être demain
sur les médicaments par cette notion de
rejet nous clamons haut et fort que nous
avons au contraire besoin d'une vraie
loi pour la hausse des salaires et le
partage des richesses
augmenter les salaires pas les
actionnaires voilà ce que vous disent
les Français avec cette motion de rejet
nous refusons la confiscation du débat
la confiscation des richesses et tout
bonnement la confiscation du juste
salaire pour les travailleurs qui seul
crée la valeur dans notre pays
merci monsieur le député
alors je vous indique je vous indique
sur la notion de rejet préalable je suis
saisie par le groupe la France insoumise
du peste d'une demande de scrutin public
que j'annonce dans l'enceinte de
l'Assemblée nationale plusieurs
explications de votes monsieur Gernigon
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente le texte qui
appelle notre présence aujourd'hui n'est
ni plus ni moins qu'une démonstration
que la démocratie sociale fonctionne en
France n'est plus ni moins que la
transposition dans la loi d'un accord de
partage de la valeur dans nos
entreprises pour les salariés signés
entre les organisations sociales et
patronales qui nous demandent
aujourd'hui de respecter ces termes
alors chers collègue la démocratie
parlementaire doit être un soutien de
cette démocratie sociale qui s'est
exprimée à la demande du gouvernement
pour améliorer les mécanismes existants
et la juste considération du travail des
salariés dans les bénéfices des
entreprises le groupe horizon votre a
contre cette motion de rejet et espère
que nous pourrons collectivement
débattre sur ce sujet crucial merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame evasas pour le groupe écologiste
UPS merci madame la Présidente je me
suis mise chers collègue pose dans le
damblée ce texte n'est en rien une
réponse au problème de pouvoir d'achat
ou de pouvoir de vivre des Français les
salaires augmentent moins vite que
l'inflation depuis le 3e trimestre 2021
les Français ont perdu en moyenne 720
euros de pouvoir d'achat en 2022 et la
facture est encore plus salée pour les
ménages ruraux et les ménage modestes
voilà le vrai problème des Français et
ce qu'ils attendent ce n'est pas une
petite prime en 2024 c'est une
augmentation de salaire dès aujourd'hui
car rappelons-le puisque vous semblez la
voir oublier le premier outil de partage
de la valeur c'est bien l'augmentation
des salaires et pourtant rien n'est
présent dans ce texte sur ce sujet bien
au contraire vous développez toutes les
alternatives possibles pour freiner les
hausses de salaire vous aviez déjà
proposé le déplafonnement des heures
supplémentaires exonérées la
modernisation des RTT la prime Macron et
maintenant ce texte sur le partage de la
valeur le groupe écologiste a pourtant
mis sur la table au travers d'une
proposition de loi de nombreuses
dispositions qui auraient pu relancer la
dynamique salariale dans notre pays
augmenter le SMIC et le point d'indice
conditionnez les aides aux entreprises à
la revalorisation des grilles salariales
réservez les exonérations basses à l'air
à une augmentation des salariés au SMIC
au bout de deux ans pour refaire du SMIC
ce qu'il aurait toujours du tête dû être
un salaire d'embauche mais rien n'y a
fait vous préférez la prime alors même
que vous connaissez son effet de
substitution aux augmentations de
salaire en moyenne à hauteur de 30%
selon l'Insee alors je comprends la
démarche de mes collègues insoumis
devant votre cynisme et ce n'est que par
respect pour la démocratie sociale qui
pour les écologistes est l'un des
piliers de la démocratie dans notre pays
que nous nous obtiendrons sur cette
motion de rejet par respect pour
l'accord conclu entre les organisations
syndicales et patronales parce que le
dialogue social et pour nous un bien
précieux un bien précieux que vous avez
malheureusement trop souvent bafouis par
respect enfin pour les organisations
syndicales et leurs combats pour la
défense des droits des salariés auxquels
je veux rendre hommage aujourd'hui je
vous remercie merci madame la députée la
parole est à Monsieur Michel Castellani
pour le groupe lot
oui merci madame la Présidente
bien sûr que ce projet de loi ne règlera
pas les inégalités de partage des
valeurs ajoutées
pas plus que nous proposera de
perspective positives en matière de
salaire ça a été dit faut-il pour autant
le balayer la balayer d'un revers de
demain nous ne croyons pas les comporte
un certain nombre d'avancés que les
trouveront une forme de concrétisation
de le quotidien des salariés que cela
soit en termes de rémunération
commentaire de participation à l'active
active à la vie de l'entreprise ça nous
y tenons nous étions beaucoup et ses
avancées bien que timides nous ne
pouvons pas selon nous les rejeter en
bloc d'autant que ce projet de loi et la
transposition d'un accord national
interprofessionnel et quel signal
enverions-nous si nous refusions
d'examiner un accord qui est né du
dialogue social
celui-ci avait été largement contourné
par le gouvernement je le rappelle ces
derniers mois nous avons été les
premiers appelés au respect du dialogue
social dans le cadre de la réforme des
retraites les premiers à exhorter le
gouvernement on essaie de partenaires
sociaux discuter des modalités de
financement du système des moyens
d'améliorer notre politique en matière
d'emploi des seniors ou de pénibilités
nous voulions qu'il présente leur
proposition surtout ce qui relève du
travail alors qu'il parviennent à un
accord majoritaire sur la question du
partage de la valeur en entreprise ah
bah cela selon nous nous oblige à cela
ne veut pas dire que nous devons
transposer à la lettre les dispositions
de cet accord n'est que nous devions pas
chercher enrichir le texte de mesure
supplémentaires nous avons notre rôle de
gélateur à jouer nous essaierons de le
faire du mieux possible et notre groupe
reste d'ailleurs je le dis au passage le
projet de loi que le projet de loi soit
si restreint
voilà alors vous avez compris pour
toutes ces raisons nous ne soutiendrons
pas cette motion de rejet merci merci
Monsieur député la parole est à Monsieur
Ferracci pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente
chers collègues de la France insoumise
avec cette motion de rejet vous montrer
une fois de plus ce que sont vos
véritables ennemis vous êtes les ennemis
du pouvoir d'achat les Français en
refusant à des millions d'entre eux
l'amélioration du revenu que permettrait
l'adoption de ce projet de loi vous êtes
les ennemis de l'emploi en préconisant
de manière parfaitement incompétente des
augmentations générales de salaire dont
on sait bien que beaucoup d'entreprises
seraient incapables de les assumer en
particulier les plus petites et les plus
jeunes d'entre elles qui cesseront
immédiatement d'embaucher vous êtes
également les ennemis du dialogue social
en refusant la transposition fidèle d'un
accord national interprofessionnel dont
on sait que la signature n'était pas du
tout acquise au départ je serais
d'ailleurs curieux à cet égard de savoir
au sein de la nupesse ce que pense ceux
et celles qui se réclame encore de la
social-démocratie dont le dialogue
social est un des piliers mais je vous
laisse discuter de cela entre vous enfin
vous êtes les ennemis du débat tout
simplement d'un débat qui pourrait
éclairer les Français
sur un sujet de préoccupation majeure
pour eux c'est le principe même d'une
motion de rejet que d'esquiver le débat
et bien nous en prenons acte dire que
tout cela mes chers collègues
nous surprend serait mentir et c'est la
raison ce sont les raisons pour
lesquelles le groupe Renaissance voca
contre cette motion de rejet merci
pour le groupe rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente donc l'accord
national interprofessionnel qui a été
voté en février de cette année voit 15
de ses 36 articles transposés dans ce
projet de loi ce qui permet de faire de
pas de plus vers le développement des
dispositifs existants au profit des
salariés alors certes le conseil d'état
indique que le critère des moins de 50
salariés pour l'inscription dans le
temps et dans le champ de l'épargne
salariale de la prime de partage de la
valeur marque une rupture d'égalité des
salariés devant l'impôt certes certaines
mesures posent problème comme le nouveau
plan de valorisation de l'entreprise qui
consiste à intéresser financièrement les
salariés à la croissance de la valeur de
leur entreprise et qui va venir
vraisemblablement effectivement
concurrence avec l'actionnariat salarié
certes le développement des outils de
partage de la valeur ne doit pas se
faire au détriment de l'augmentation des
salaires qui restent le meilleur partage
de la valeur
certes ce projet de loi ne comporte
aucune disposition contre la pratique de
la fraude fiscale évaluée à environ 40
milliards d'euros soit 20 fois plus
qu'au début des années 2000 ce qui grève
la participation bien sûr des salariés
mais ce projet de loi va permettre
d'étendre la participation dans les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés de
faire bénéficier aux salariés des
bénéfices exceptionnels de leur
entreprise et de développer
l'actionnariat salarié dans le capital
des entreprises françaises surtout c'est
une transposition dans la loi de
l'accord national interprofessionnelle
signé en février de cette année par
toutes les organisations syndicales de
salariés patronales à l'exception c'est
vrai de la CGT au terme de plusieurs
semaines de discussion alors ne pas en
discuter serait donc une trahison
vis-à-vis de ces syndicats des
différents organismes que nous avons pu
auditionner et qui se sont tous déclarés
en faveur d'une évolution des
dispositifs de partage de la valeur
alors dans la mesure où nous ne sommes
pas liés à la CGT comme peut l'être les
nupesses nous voterons contre votre
motion de rejet dans l'intérêt des
salariés des Français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame kaki pour le groupe elle est
finupes
merci madame la Présidente collègue le
projet de loi que vous nous demandez de
voter aujourd'hui est complètement
hypocrite certains cadeaux de plus pour
les patrons et les superficeurs votre
projet de loi est une insulte au
travailleuse au travailleur du pays oui
c'est une insulte car il ne propose que
des primes et des mesures qui affaiblit
notre système social et le mettre en
danger rien sur le SMIC rien sur la
taxation d'un super profit rien sur
l'égalité salariale femme homme rien le
pouvoir d'achat recule sous le coup de
l'inflexion le pays compte un million
200000 travailleurs et travailleurs
pauvres mais vous refusez d'agir vous
auriez pu améliorer cet accord et
proposer au minimum des augmentations de
chimiques mais non vous préférez
condamner le peuple et la générations
futures à deux années de travail de plus
avec votre réforme de retraite
brutal injuste et un populaire vous
préférez ça plutôt que d'exiger de vos
amis super riches et mettre la main à la
poche
[Applaudissements]
les salariés à se mettre en grève pour
exiger des augmentations de salaire à
Monoprix total jeudi
Ibis et ailleurs c'est grâce à la grève
que les salaires ont été augmentés je
tiens à rendre ici hommage on se sent
douze 72
travailleuses devaient bodets c'est
parce qu'elles ont tenu deux mois sans
salaire qu'elles ont arraché leur
victoire
collègue rejeter ce test vide et voter
notre motion de rejet nous sommes les
représentants du peuple et le peuple
veut travailler dignement et gagner sa
vie dignement c'est ni le sens de ce
projet ni qu'attend le peuple de France
merci merci madame la députée la parole
est à Monsieur virée pour le groupe les
républicains
merci
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues il est temps que l'Assemblée
nationale se saisisse de la question du
partage de la valeur dans l'entreprise
ça a été travaillé c'était préparé par
émission d'information déposée en avril
dernier qui démontre bien que dans le
dispositif applicable dans notre droit
il y a des carences et que des
aménagements sont nécessaires et moi je
conviens effectivement que le projet de
loi il peut être le prétexte a évoquer
tous les toutes les questions liées à
l'emploi au pouvoir d'achat à la
rémunération à la place du travail ce
que cherche à nous faire faire la nupes
en déportant le sujet le sujet à mon
avis il est pas là il est de savoir si
oui ou non on respecte le dialogue
social
on respecte le travail élaboré par des
organisations syndicales et des
organisations patronales qui ont
déterminé un chemin au bénéfice des
travailleurs
ne pas valider cet accord national
interprofessionnel c'est à mes yeux
faire une insulte aux partenaires
sociaux
c'est considéré effectivement que ce
qu'ils ont fait est à jeter et que
l'Assemblée nationale aurait pour
mission
d'écraser la démocratie sociale parce
que seule la démocratie parlementaire
aurait la vérité dans ce pays je ne
partage pas avec mes collègues les
répliquants c'est cette vision on
considère que ce projet loi qui cherche
à transcrire
un accord
déterminé par les partenaires sociaux
doit être respectées c'est la raison
pour lequel par respect pour les
partenaires sociaux voteront contre
cette notion de rejet la voté c'est
opposer une fin de non-recevoir au
dialogue social au patron et aux
salariés c'est insupportable pour moi
merci monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur millienne pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la Présidente comme à
chaque mandature je pense que plusieurs
d'entre nous écrirons sûrement un livre
pour raconter leur expérience de députés
il y a déjà le célèbre excellent manuel
de survie à l'Assemblée nationale de
Jean-Jacques Urvoas nos collègues de la
France insoumise n'auront qu'à mal à
publier un épée manuel de l'opposition
stérile je leur suggère de dédier un
chapitre entier autour de force qui a
été réussie aujourd'hui
foulée au pied le dialogue social et
refuser d'examiner un texte majeur pour
le pouvoir d'achat des salariés en
particulier ceux des petites et moyennes
entreprises le groupe démocrate était
impatient de députés d'examen de ce
projet de loi fruit d'un quasi consensus
entre partenaires sociaux nous avons une
occasion unique de mieux associer des
salariés à la valeur qu'ils ont
contribué à créer
pourtant à défaut d'un texte
correspondant exactement à la vision
punitive de la France insoumise nous
avons à nous prononcer sur une motion de
rejet collègue mélenchoniste obsédé par
le grand soir vous refusez de débattre
du moindre pas en avant du moindre
compromis entre patrons et salariés vous
dites défendre les travailleurs les plus
modestes mais croyez-vous vraiment que
ne m'aime pas examiner ce projet de loi
va les aider non vous dites soutenir la
négociation syndicale mais vous vous
dérobez au moment de la transcrire dans
la loi où est la logique il y en a pas
quels sont les avancées concrètes aucune
le partage de la valeur dans
l'entreprise ce sont plus de 18
milliards d'euros vers ses parents soit
environ 2500 euros par salarié dans les
structures de plus de 10 personnes
demain demain si le Parlement vote le
texte nous sommes assis nous sommes nous
sommes saisis dont nous sommes saisis
pardon ce sont les salariés de 50000
entreprises supplémentaires qui auront
accès à un dispositif de partage de la
valeur l'actionnariat salarié sera quant
à lui élargie et une épargne salariale
plus importante contribuera à la
transition écologique pour toutes ces
raisons et parce que nous ne sommes pas
de la CGT le groupe démocrate tient à
débattre et voter en faveur de ce texte
sur le partage de la valeur mes chers
collègues faisons de même merci Monsieur
députés la parole est à Monsieur géant
Guedj concours socialiste et apparentés
merci madame la Présidente d'abord je
voudrais dire à l'ensemble de nos
collègues qu'il y a une contradiction un
oxymore à vanter les vertus du dialogue
social d'un côté et comme ça vient
d'être fait à l'instant par Bruno
millième de vouer au gémodi au gémonie
un départements sociaux en stigmatisant
un des partenaires qui a refusé de
signer de l'accord c'est le propre du
dialogue social de signer des accords de
ne pas signer les accords et donc
conseil comment je vous invite à d'abord
tempérer les excès d'enthousiasme dont
vous pourriez faire preuve à l'appui de
ce texte un peu comme la fée tout à
l'heure Marc Ferracci en considérant que
ce texte était l'alpha et l'oméga du
partage de la valeur il souffre
d'insuffisance manifeste ce texte et
elle procède pas uniquement de la
qualité du dialogue social mais on en
reparlera tout au long des débats du
document d'orientation du ministre
quand le ministre dans un document
d'orientation en application de
l'article L1 du Code du travail dit aux
partenaires sociaux voilà les sujets sur
lequel je souhaite que vous discutiez et
que dans les sujets
identifiés il n'est pas fait mention une
seule fois de la question des salaires
c'est donc bien le gouvernement lui-même
qui veut évacuer cette question des
salaires de ce sujet central du partage
de la valeur et donc nous allons tout au
long de ces débats faire preuve de notre
frustration parce que vous avez
cadenacées à nouveau le travail des
partenaires sociaux comme vous
connaissez souvent le travail des
parlementaires pour autant et je le dis
dans les secondes qui me restent par
respect nous aussi pour la démocratie
sociale et pour le dialogue social nous
souhaitons que le débat puisse puisse
avoir lieu et que notamment dans ce
débat vous puissiez nous expliquer à
quel moment et comment vous êtes les
gardiens zélés de ce dialogue social en
disant ce qui est acceptable ou ce qui
n'est pas acceptable parce que nous
allons avoir cette confrontation tout au
long de nos discussions dans les jours
qui viennent entre la démocratisation
sociale que nous appelons de nos vœux
mais aussi le le nécessaire démocratie
parlementaire qui ne peut pas se
soumettre à la démocratie sociale c'est
ce que nous allons vérifier dans le
débat que nous allons avoir maintenant
que nous souhaitons et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous nous abstiendrons
cette motion de rejet merci Monsieur
député je mets maintenant aux voiles la
motion de rejet préalable je vous invite
à regagner vos places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
beau temps 110 exprimé 106 majorité 54
pour 32 contre 74 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté
nous passons maintenant à la discussion
générale avec tout d'abord Monsieur
François Gernigon pour 5 minutes et pour
le groupe horizon et à parenté
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales chers
collègues
depuis 2017 notre majorité a porté
plusieurs réformes ambitieuses avec un
objectif fondamental atteindre le plein
emploi aujourd'hui nous pouvons être
fiers de le constater et de le dire
notre taux de chômage est au plus bas
qu'il n'ait été au cours des quatre
dernières décennies
mais nous savons que l'emploi ne se
résume pas à des chiffres il s'agit
aussi de travailler mieux dans des
conditions améliorées et avec une
reconnaissance accrue de chacun
dans cette perspective le partage de la
valeur en entreprise est un outil de
premier ordre
c'est dans ce contexte que la corne
national interprofessionnelle acquiert
une importance cruciale
c'est un moyen de concrétiser des
engagements et de poursuivre notre
mission collective pour un marché du
travail plus équitable et plus inclusif
c'est également un effort conjoint signé
le 10 février 2023 avec les trois
principales organisations patronales
représentatives et 4 des 5 organisations
syndicales représentatives
la mobilisation des acteurs sociaux dans
l'élaboration de cet accord est un
exemple de collaboration démontrant que
la démocratie sociale reste une force
motrice pour l'amélioration des droits
des travailleurs et du fonctionnement
des entreprises
s'il vous plaît l'année répond à un
double objectif améliorer la répartition
de la valeur créée et mieux récompenser
les salariés en cas de performance
exceptionnelle des entreprises
ils permettra d'inclure davantage les
salariés dans les bénéfices de
l'entreprise
cet accord s'inscrit dans le
prolongement des initiatives portées par
les gouvernements et notre majorité pour
booster l'intéressement et la
participation spécialement dans les
petites entreprises la loi pacte de 2019
en est un exemple important
il s'inscrit également dans la suite
logique du renforcement de la prime de
partage de la valeur grâce à la loi
pouvoir d'achat du 16 août 2022 prime
dont ont bénéficié plus de 5 millions de
salariés l'année précédente et dont les
limites ont été augmentées pour
atteindre 3000 euros par an par
bénéficiaire sans condition et jusqu'à
6000 euros pour les entreprises ayant
adopté un accord d'intéressement ou de
participation volontaire
l'article 3 établi une étape importante
dans le parcours vers une meilleure
équité en invitant les entreprises de 11
à 50 salariés à mettre en place un
dispositif de partage de la valeur tout
en le refant une certaine latitude quant
à sa nature participation intéressement
prime de partage de la valeur
contribution à un plan d'épargne
entreprise ou un plan d'épargne retraite
l'article 5 de ce projet de loi prévoit
également une meilleure prise en compte
des résultats exceptionnels avec
l'obligation dans les entreprises de
plus de 50 salariés d'ouvrir des
négociations afin de verser un
supplément aux salariés en cas de
résultat réalisé en France et présentant
un caractère exceptionnel que les
organisations patronales et syndicales
n'ont pas souhaité définir et qui nous
appartiendra de préciser au cours de ce
débat
j'ai d'ailleurs déposé avec mes
collègues du groupe horizon et parenté
un amendement afin de préciser les
critères qui devront être prises en
compte pour la définition de
l'augmentation exceptionnelle du
bénéfice
pour conclure je tiens à saluer
l'engagement du gouvernement et le
soutien indéfectible à cet accord dans
sa détermination à transposer fidèlement
et rapidement ses règles en loi telles
qu'il était annoncé
cette démarche témoigne de l'importance
accordée à la démocratie sociale et au
travail accompli en collaboration avec
les partenaires sociaux
il va sans dire que le groupe horizon
apparteront ce soutien sans réserve à ce
texte je vous remercie merci monsieur le
député
la parole est à Madame evaas pour le
groupe écologiste nupais c'est pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues je l'ai dit
précédemment ce texte n’étant rien une
réponse au problème de pouvoir d'achat
des Français le premier outil de partage
la valeur c'est l'augmentation des
salaires et c'est ce qu'attend
aujourd'hui les Françaises et les
Français et nous ne sommes pas dupes du
fait que cette négociation initiée sur
le partage de la valeur n'est que le
énième épisode de votre politique très
constante qui consiste à développer
toutes les alternatives permettant au
contraire de freiner les augmentations
de salaire mais nous aurions pu
néanmoins à vous rejoindre sur ce projet
de loi s'il avait étendu l'obligation de
la participation pour les entreprises de
11 à 50 salariés cela aurait été une
avancée réelle car oui nous avons
aujourd'hui dans notre pays un salariat
à deux vitesses avec d'un côté les
salariés des grands groupes qui sont
déjà les mieux rémunérés et qui ont
accès à l'intéressement à la
participation et à l'éping salariale
et de l'autre les salariés des TPE PME
déjà moins bien rémunérés et qui s'envoi
privée mais ce n'est malheureusement pas
ce que propose ce texte et il n'aura en
l'état qu'une portée très faible et ce
pour trois raisons d'abord parce que
vous avez cyniquement introduit la prime
Macron dans les outils de partage de la
valeur en la rebaptisant habilement
prime de partage de la valeur encore une
opération de communication pour
promouvoir cette prime une prime qui
comme je l'ai rappelé a un effet
d'éviction de 30% en moyenne sur les
augmentations de salaire et qui va de
plus venir cannibaliser l'intéressement
la prime étant beaucoup plus simple à
mettre en oeuvre et moins coûteuse que
ce dispositif
l'intéressement et la participation sont
eux des dispositifs vertueux négociés et
qui fédèrent un collectif de travail
autour d'objectifs partagés mais non
vous poussez la prime en disant qu'elle
est plébiscitée mes plébiscités par qui
parlez employeurs évidemment zéro charge
zéro négociation et un AR pour les
entreprises pour proposer de moindres
augmentations de salaire mais les
salariés eux veulent une augmentation
sur leur fiche de paye tous les mois
pour payer leurs factures pour pouvoir
emprunter pour pouvoir se projeter
deuxièmement il n'y a aucun minimum de
versement fixé dans la loi un employeur
d'une entreprise de 11 à 50 salariés
pour adélor ce contenter de verser une
prime de 1 euro pour satisfaire ses
obligations légales et troisième raison
ce texte prévoit le versement d'une
prime exceptionnelle qu'en entreprise
réalise des résultats exceptionnels mais
il n'y a dans ce projet de loi qu'une
obligation de négocier sur la définition
des résultats exceptionnels et rien
n'est prévu si la négociation échoue
autant dire que l'effectivité de ce
droit est entièrement conditionnée à la
bonne volonté de l'employeur les
écologistes sont de fervent défenseur de
la démocratie sociale il n'y a pas de
démocratie sans démocratie sociale et je
veux rendre ici hommage aux
organisations syndicales et aux 2,5
millions de syndiqués en France
qui chaque jour le courage de défendre
des salariés mais rien n'empêche les
parlementaires d'améliorer ce texte
c'est pourquoi nous vous proposerons au
travers de nos amendements dans
renforcer la portée en réservant les
exonérations à la participation et à
l'intéressement en fixant un minimum de
prime versées dans les entreprises de 11
à 55 salariés et en définissant de
manière supplétive ce que sont les
résultats exceptionnels en cas d'échec
de la négociation mais surtout ne devons
absolument au travers de ce projet de
loi nous attaquer aux employeurs peu
scrupuleux qui prive les salariés de
leurs droits à participer à son en
déplaçant la valeur ajoutée dans des
holdings en France ou à l'étranger on ne
peut pas parler d'un juste partage de la
valeur si les salariés injustements
privés de leur participation ne peuvent
même pas poursuivre leur employeur pour
obtenir réparation or aujourd'hui il ne
le peuvent pas à cause d'un article du
code de travail le l3326-1
un verrou juridique qui n'a qu'un seul
effet protéger les employeurs douteux
des poursuites de leurs salariés
Xerox volters cloverse McDonald's autant
d'affaires qui ont défrayé la chronique
et où les salariés demandant leur juste
droit à participation ont été déboutés
sur la base d'un seul article le fameux
l3326-1 dans le cas de Procter un Gumble
c'est 5,5 milliards d'euros de valeur
ajoutée qui ont été transférées en
Suisse par le biais de près de transfert
occasionnant une perte de 371 millions
d'euros de participation pour les
salariés pour General Electric le
transfert de base fiscale est estimé à
850 milliards d'euros pour les années
2015 à 2020
occasionnant une perte de participation
de 10,5 millions d'euros pour les
salariés pour nous ce sera l'épreuve des
vérité sur ce texte êtes-vous là pour
protéger les employeurs malhonnêtes ou
pour défendre le juste droit des
salariés à participation
je voudrais finir en rendant hommage au
travail à la qualité d'écoute du
rapporteur de ce texte Louis Marguerite
avec qui nous avons eu un dialogue
constructif malgré nos désaccords je ne
peux qu'espérer qu'ils soient mieux
écouter à son tour par le gouvernement
je vous remercie madame la député la
parole est à Monsieur Pierre Daredevil
pour le groupe rouge démocrates et
républicain up c'est pour 5 minutes
merci
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers et chers collègues
opération pousse-mousse de la mousse
pour faire croire que le Gouvernement
est favorable au partage et pas
n'importe quel partage le partage de la
valeur presque le partage des richesses
un truc complètement disruptif rien à
voir avec la réforme des retraites de la
mousse pour nous expliquer que les
relations sociales dans le pays sont au
nirvana puisque un accord a été signé
qui nous est demandé d'acter dans la loi
alors moi aussi j'aime beaucoup la
fiction mais vous aurez quand même du
mal à nous embarquer dans ce délire car
l'histoire que le président et ses amis
écrivent jour après jour c'est celle de
l'abondance pour une poignée de
quelques-uns c'est celle des inégalités
c'est celle des bas salaires c'est celle
de l'incertitude du lendemain c'est
celle de la sécurité sociale à sécher
c'est celle des retraites rabotées tout
a été fait pour organiser le
contournement et même en réalité la
relégation au second plan du salaire à
chaque occasion nous contestons la
feuille de route que vous avez imposée à
cet accord qui ne fait pas l'unanimité
c'est le résultat de cette feuille de
route que nous examinons aussi quand
est-ce qu'on parle du salaire
cet accord le dit et il faut se battre
pour vous en arracher une
retranscription il ne saurait y avoir de
substitution du salaire par les primes
c'est pourtant le cas à hauteur de
30%. et cela risque de se poursuivre
nous vivons sous l'empire du profit et
il s'étend de jour en jour entre 2011 et
2021 selon les derniers rapports d'Oxfam
pour ce qui concerne les 100 plus
grandes entreprises françaises côté la
part dédiée à la rémunération du travail
dans la valeur ajoutée à chuté de 10
points elles ont versé à leurs
actionnaires en moyenne 71% de ce
qu'elles ont gagné chaque année les PDG
a augmenté leur rémunération de 66%
tandis que celle des salariés
n'augmenter que de 21% et le SMIC de 14%
les politiques conduites par le
Président c'est gouvernements et ses
majorités ont accompagné accrédité
accélérer ce mouvement toujours plus
pour les grands possédants pour les
dominants au détriment de celles et ceux
qui n'ont pour vivre que leur force de
travail et c'est pourtant leur travail
qui crée les richesses le partage de la
valeur commence par le salaire il réside
même essentiellement dans le salaire le
salaire installe la rémunération dans la
durée garantie des droits constituent le
fil rouge tout au long de la carrière
professionnelle ce n'est pas à nous que
vous ferez dire qu'il ne faut pas mieux
partager les richesses mais ce n'est pas
à nous que vous ferez croire que vous
voulez vraiment le faire avec ce texte
voici bien longtemps que nous proposons
par exemple une échelle des salaires
permettant de limiter les écarts de
rémunération les bons effets de cet
accord seront limités les contrefaits
eux seront bien au rendez-vous vous n'en
finissez plus de priver la sécurité
sociale de ressources vous êtes
allergique c'est le sentiment qu'on a à
l'idée même de cotisation sociale ce
n'est pas ça la cotisation sociale c'est
ce qui nous permet de nous assurer
mutuellement face aux aléas de
l'existence à cet endroit apparaît
d'ailleurs le glissement opéré
suppression des ressources pour la
sécurité sociale et les retraites d'un
côté et plan de capitalisation
encouragés de l'autre nous le savions
déjà lorsque vous vous livriez il y a
quelques temps à de grandes tirades
selon lesquelles vous étiez là pour
sauver le système par répartition la
religion de la prime va avec la
capitalisation cela fait système le
partage de la valeur c'est au sein de
l'entreprise bien sûr mais c'est aussi à
l'échelle de toute la société par le
biais de l'impôt et de la justice
fiscale vous essayez de vendre par
ailleurs l'illusion de l'actionnariat
salarié comme une libération comme si en
distribuant quelques actions qui nous
donnent aucun pouvoir réel on pouvait
abolir le lien de subordination entre
l'employeur et le salarié abolir la
contradiction de classe il ne s'agit que
de faire semblant et de créer la
confusion alors donner plutôt des
salaires juste et devraient pouvoir aux
salariés vous leur en avez retiré y
compris sur la santé leur sécurité je
veux aujourd'hui avoir
une pensée mobilisée pour les salariés
d'ArcelorMittal l'inspection du travail
vient de prononcer l'arrêt de leur
activité pour mise en protection face à
une exposition grave à des émissions
cancérigènes mutagène et reprotoxiques à
Fos-sur-Mer cet accord dont on a le
sentiment qu'il a pour partie était
signé faute de mieux ne fait pas comme
on dit la rue Michel il fait pour partir
reposer sur les finances de la sécurité
sociale et de l'état la valeur partagée
en question vous avez donné une mauvaise
feuille de route aux organisations
syndicales et patronales la puissance
publique doit prendre partie autrement
dans les rapports sociaux en faveur de
celles et ceux qui les subissent nous
regardons donc pas ce texte avec une
sorte de neutralité car au stade où nous
en sommes il nous engage il va nous
engager et parce que la manière de le
transcrire elle n'est pas neutre non
plus pour faire beaucoup de mousse
monsieur le ministre il n'y a pas besoin
de beaucoup de savon
merci Monsieur député la parole est à
Monsieur Michel Castellani pour le
groupe liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire et pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission ce rapporteur mes chers
collègues cela a été dit déjà mais si
nous devions retenir qu'une donnée ce
serait celle tirer du rapport aux femmes
en disant dans les sens plus grandes
entreprises françaises côté la dépense
par salarié a augmenté de 22 % et les
versements aux actionnaires de
57%. c'est la preuve d'un écueil majeur
de notre système de répartition de
richesse au sein des entreprises et plus
largement au sein de la société la
preuve comme des pays de la volonté de
développer des outils de partage de la
valeur ces dernières années nous
touchons du doigt leur limite nous ne
pouvons demeurer indifférents de part à
la croissement des mesurée des
rémunérations sous forme de dividendes
et d'action et d'autre part aux
difficultés croissantes des salariés à
vivre des fruits de leur travail
il y a là une impasse qui doit un minima
nous questionner sur notre capacité à
lutter réellement contre les injustices
sociales
le projet de loi que nous sommes amenés
à examiner aujourd'hui ne résoudra pas
cet écueil néanmoins notre groupe se
satisfait de voir advenir un accord
national interprofessionnel le dialogue
social fonctionne bien lorsque nous
laissons les partenaires sociaux
négociés d'autant que le sujet de
partage de la valeur était essentiel
pour répondre à l'enjeu de pouvoir
d'achat préoccupation majeure des
citoyens mais aussi pour tenir compte de
l'évolution des rapports au travail et
de la demande d'engagement au sein des
entreprises
toutefois le présent projet de loi ne
reprend pas toujours intégralement le
contenu de la corne national ce qui
remet en cause son équilibre nous
proposerons quelques ajustements au
cours du débat si notre groupe soutient
le développement de dispositif de
partage de la valeur nous alertons sur
deux points majeurs d'abord ces outils
ne peuvent et ne doivent pas se
substituer au salaire
considérer que la question de
rémunération se réglera par ce biais
serait erroné les primes ne constituent
pas une politique salariale
satisfaisante un minima il conviendrait
de décorer les négociations portant sur
les salaires de cette relative au
partage de la valeur nous portons un
amendement en ce sens en effet les
effets de substitution de la prime
Macron c'est un exemple au salaire sont
importants entre 15 et 40 euros auraient
été accordés en salaire sans cette prime
il faut donc être très vigilant sur ces
effets d'aubaine autre problème ces
outils ne profitent pas à tous les
salariés il y a toutes les entreprises
et le texte ne se traduira pas en une
automaticité de ses primes enfin le
calcul des primes avantages parfois le
haut de l'échelle des salaires plutôt
que les plus petites rémunérations sur
ce point la Cour nationale propose
toutefois des évolutions intéressantes à
l'inverse ce qui devrait être un point
important à savoir la prise en compte
des résultats exceptionnels demeure
timide dans ce texte rien ne garantit
que la mesure aboutira
une autre réserve concerne la complexité
de ces outils une réflexion sur des
règles en matière de régime fiscal et
social nous paraît nécessaire
d'une part pour en faciliter l'accès et
la compréhension mais aussi pour mesurer
de l'impact sur la sécurité sociale en
effet la dresse estime que ces dépenses
fiscales et sociales ce dispositif de
partage de roller ont entraîné 8
milliards de moins de recettes pour la
sécurité sociale entre 2018 et 2022
cela est loin d'être anodin à l'heure où
nous manquons cruellement de recettes
pour pérenniser notre modèle de
protection sociale par ailleurs la
propagation de régime sociaux et fiscaux
qui devaient être exceptionnels risquent
de poser quelques problèmes en matière
d'égalité devant les charges publiques
que nous y reviendrons notre groupe
estime qu'une discussions sur le partage
de la valeur en entreprise doit aussi
pouvoir tendre faire une plus grande
conditionnalité des aides nous
défendrons un amendement ayant pour
objectif d'inscrire dans la loi la
possibilité d'intégrer les critères RSE
des critères financiers nous devons pas
être les seuls à figurer dans les
accords dans le même esprit la prise en
compte des résultats exceptionnels dans
le texte nous paraît encore timide et
gagnerait à être plus encadré de même
que la définition de ces derniers qui
demeurent encore élastique
voilà c'est remarques est en fait je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure notre groupe
pour soutiendra ce PJL je vous remercie
merci monsieur le député
la parole est à Madame Michel perron
pour le groupe Renaissance et pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues
depuis 2017 nous menons des réformes
pour favoriser le développement des
dispositifs de partage de la valeur au
sein de la loi pacte de 2019 nous avons
notamment mis en place des accords
d'intéressement et de participation dans
les PME
plus récemment en août dernier à travers
la loi porte en mesure d'urgence pour la
protection du pouvoir d'achat où nous
avons facilité une nouvelle fois le
recours à l'intéressement au sein des
PME est instauré une nouvelle prime de
partage de la valeur qui a remplacé la
prime dite Macron la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat mais
nous souhaitons aller plus loin c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement a invité en
septembre dernier les partenaires
sociaux à engager une négociation
nationale interprofessionnelle afin de
renforcer le partage de la valeur au
sein des entreprises et d'améliorer
l'association des salariés aux
performances de l'entreprise les
partenaires sociaux se sont donc
investis de ce sujet entamé des travaux
c'est donc sur cette base qu'un accord
national interprofessionnel a été conclu
le 10 février 2022
cette année a été signée par les
organisations patronales Medef CPME et
u2p ainsi que les organisations
syndicales suivantes CFDT cgcftc Force
Ouvrière c'est ainsi que le gouvernement
s'est engagé à transposer fidèlement
cette année conclut entre les
partenaires sociaux à travers des
mesures ambitieuses la première de ces
mesures est l'instauration obligatoire
pour les entreprises constituées de 11 à
49 salariés d'un dispositif de partage
de la valeur au choix entre l'accord de
participation l'accord d'intéressement
le versement d'une prime de partage de
la valeur ou l'abondement à un plan
d'épargne et salariale la seconde
prévoir l'instauration d'une obligation
de négociation sur la prise en compte
des résultats exceptionnels pour les
entreprises d'au moins 50 salariés les
débats en commission des affaires
sociales ont été relativement
constructifs la majorité a notamment
fait adopter un amendement sur la mixité
des métiers afin de mettre en place un
bilan des actions des branches en faveur
de la promotion et l'amélioration de la
mixité des métiers conformément à
l'article 4 de l'année nous avons
également adopté un amendement de notre
rapporteur visant à accélérer la
généralisation des dispositifs de la
valeur dans les entreprises d'au moins
11 salariés et de moins de 50 salariés
un avançant à 2024 la mise en œuvre du
dispositif prévu à l'article 3 de ce
projet de loi
au regard de nos débats en commission et
aux échanges qui avaient lieu en
simultané entre les partenaires sociaux
nous proposerons un amendement
d'équilibre sur l'annonce substitution
selon lequel les sommes versées au titre
de dispositifs de partage de la valeur
ne peuvent pas se substituer au salaire
nous proposerons également un amendement
sur les bénéfices exceptionnels afin de
pallier à des manques pointées par le
Conseil d'État nous porterons également
un amendement afin de transposer
l'article 15 de l'année afin que
l'accord d'intéressement puisse prendre
en compte des critères relevants de la
responsabilité sociale et
environnementale de l'entreprise enfin
en accord avec les organisations
syndicales signataires nous proposons
d'appliquer les obligations présentes au
sein de l'article 3 du projet de loi aux
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire je souhaite enfin exprimer un
regret
un regret de voir qu'une fois de plus un
certain groupe de l'opposition se
servent de cette tribune pour faire un
show médiatique et mentir aux Français
qui sommes-nous pour nous opposer à un
accord signé par temps de partenaires
sociaux qui sommes-nous pour nier de
nouveaux dispositifs qui augmenteront le
pouvoir d'achat de près de 1 million 500
000 de français si nous ne serons jamais
d'accord sur le point des salaires
comment pouvez-vous refuser des mesures
issues d'un tel accord ce projet de loi
n'empêche à aucun moment les entreprises
à augmenter les salaires cela a été fait
dans certains secteurs nous ne pouvons
plus vous laisser dire que les patrons
sont des personnes avides qui ne
partagent pas et rechignent à partager
certains bénéfices c'est faux
les masques tombent vous ne respectez
pas le dialogue et la démocratie sociale
s'il vous plaît le groupe Renaissance
fidèle à son engagement de respect de la
démocratie sociale
soutiendra ce projet de loi merci merci
madame la députée la parole que Frédéric
cabriolier
pour le groupe rassemblement national et
pour 5 minutes
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur madame
la présidente de la commission des
affaires sociales chers collègues le
partage de la valeur dans les
entreprises entre les salariés les
actionnaires et un des enjeux majeurs
dans les années à venir à la fois pour
le pouvoir d'achat et pour réconcilier
les Français avec le monde de
l'entreprise un fossé c'est creusé ces
dernières années entre salariés et
actionnaires dans la répartition travail
et capital on observe ainsi sur les 30
dernières années une déformation du
partage de la valeur ajoutée en faveur
du capital au détriment du travail les
chiffres de 2020 quant au développement
des dispositifs de partage de la valeur
place en effet la France en deuxième
position derrière la Slovénie les lois
pacte de 2019 ASAP de 2020 et celle
relative au pouvoir d'achat de l'année
dernière ont beaucoup contribué au
déploiement des différents dispositifs
en simplifiant les procédures
administratives pour les chefs
d'entreprise et en sécurisant les
entreprises une une fois l'accord mis en
place l'accord nationale
interprofessionnel votée en février de
cette année voit donc 16 15 de ses 36
articles transposés dans ce projet de
loi ce qui permet de faire un pas de
plus vers le développement des
dispositifs existants au profit des
salariés le déploiement de la
participation et de l'intéressement dans
les entreprises de moins de 50 salariés
devraient se traduire par plus de
productivité dans les entreprises la
possibilité de négocier un apport de
participation d'ici juin 2024 avec une
liberté totale sur la fixation de la
formule du calcul de la participation
qui peut être moins disante que la
formule légale ou la généralisation des
dispositifs de partage de la valeur aux
entreprises de 11 à 50 salariés qui
réalisent des bénéfices récurrents
doivent permettre d'étendre la
participation dans les entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés la volonté de faire
bénéficier aux salariés des bénéfices
exceptionnels de leur entreprise en
temps répondent à une question de
justice sociale même si les regrettable
que le législateur n'est pas ce qu'est
une augmentation exceptionnelle du
bénéfice l'inscription dans le temps et
dans le champ de l'épargne salariale de
la prime de partage de la valeur en
permettant sa prolongation au 31
décembre 2026 en temps répondre à une
problématique de pouvoir d'achat le
Conseil d'État estime toutefois que ce
critère de la taille de l'entreprise à
savoir moins de 55 salariés pour pouvoir
bénéficier de l'exonération de l'impôt
sur le revenu en cas de placement dans
de l'épargne salariale porte atteinte
aux principes d'égalité devant la peau
l'augmentation des fonds de capital
attribuables pour les attributions
d'action gratuites devraient contribuer
à l'objectif affiché de 10%
d'actionnariats des salariés français
dans le capital des entreprises
françaises à horizon 2030 il s'agit d'un
enjeu de souveraineté économique de
confiance et d'implication à long terme
des salariés dans leur entreprise et un
renforcement de la responsabilité
sociale des entreprises toutefois il y a
des incohérences dans ce projet de loi
comme le fait que les une entreprise de
l'économie sociale et solidaire soit
incluse dans les dispositions concernant
la participation alors que ce sont des
entreprises à but non lucratif qui ne
les dégages pas de bénéfices mais on en
a parlé effectivement en commission
certaines remarques nous ont été aussi
formulés lors des différentes auditions
comme le nouveau plan de valorisation de
l'entreprise qui consiste à intéresser
financièrement les salariés à la
croissance de la valeur de leur
entreprise en venant en concurrence avec
l'actionnariat salarié plus compliqué à
mettre en oeuvre ce nouveau dispositif
dispositif risque de fragiliser
l'édifice de l'actionnariat salarié dans
certaines entreprises côté lors des
différentes auditions il est également
ressorti la nécessité d'assurer une
meilleure lisibilité de ces dispositifs
de partage de la valeur ainsi qu'une
certaine stabilité tant sur le plan
législatif que sur le plan socio fiscal
il est également important que le
développement de ces outils de partage
de la valeur ne se fassent pas au
détriment de l'augmentation des qui
reste le meilleur partage de la valeur
dans le cadre des négociations
obligatoires prévues par le Code du
travail il faudra imposer des
négociations séparées sur les salaires
et sur les dispositifs d'épargne
salariale comme d'ailleurs l'ont demandé
les syndicats aujourd'hui la
participation et l'intéressement
représente 6% de la masse salariale dans
les entreprises où elles ont été mises
en place selon le CNRS soit 2% ont eu un
impact négatif sur les augmentations de
salaire aussi contrairement à ce que
répète à l'envie la nupes le RN
permettra aux entreprises qui le
souhaitent d'augmenter les salaires de
10% jusqu'à trois fois le SMIC en les
exonérant de charge patronales à
Ferrante enfin les chiffres du partage
de la valeur sont faussés par la
pratique de la fraude fiscale évaluée à
40 milliards d'euros on déplore que dans
ce projet de loi il n'y a aucune
disposition qui permettrait de lutter
contre ces transferts de profit ce qui
grève bien entendu la participation des
salariés je vous remercie
merci Monsieur débuter la parole est à
Madame Aurélie trouvée pour le groupe la
France insoumise mupestre
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre collègue lorsque nous avons su
que le gouvernement proposait un projet
de loi nommé partage de la valeur dans
l'entreprise je me suis dit enfin nous
allons discuter des salaires et proposer
pourquoi pas des solutions à tous les
gens qui souffrent de l'inflation dans
ce pays ce qui serait la moindre des
choses quand on sait que les salaires
connaissent une chute historique de plus
de 2%. alors que l'inflation est au plus
haut et quand même temps les profits
augmentent de façon inouïe alors pleine
d'espoir j'ai pensé que peut-être le
caractère exceptionnel de cette
situation pourrait amener le plus
néolibéral de tous les présidents de la
Cinquième République à s'interroger j'ai
donc parcouru le projet de loi avec
grand intérêt cherchant où il était
question de salaire et de profit et là
surprise parce que de l'article 1 à
l'article 15 pas une seule disposition
qui organise la hausse des salaires pas
une seule on nous propose donc un texte
de loi consacré au partage de la valeur
dans l'entreprise qui ne traite jamais
du partage de la valeur en fait c'est
une loi que je pourrais appeler tout
sauf les salaires c'est à dire prime
intéressement participation mais jamais
au grand jamais les salaires tout sauf
les salaires et bien que se passe-t-il
du coup le SMIC lui suit l'inflation
c'est bien normal c'est la loi mais vous
vous refusez à faire quoi que ce soit de
plus alors évidemment les salaires qui
sont juste au-dessus se tassent eux au
niveau du SMIC tant pis donc pour cette
salarié de Monoprix Sylvie 38 ans
d'ancienneté qui gagne 50 euros de plus
que le SMIC tout sauf les salaires
quelques primes certes que les patrons
peuvent distribuer selon leur bonne
volonté Sylvie toujours la même en
reçoit quelques-unes minuscules et
diminuées par exemple en cas de congé
maladie alors les primes vous le voyez
bien permettent aux grands patrons
d'exiger des salariés de venir
travailler même malade en crever voilà
ce que vous voulez encourager et dont
rêve par ailleurs le patron de Monoprix
IX et tous les patrons patrons qui lui
d'ailleurs a doublé son salaire l'année
dernière pour atteindre plus d'un
million d'euros
tout sauf les salaires tout sauf les
droits à la retraite et au chômage parce
que votre projet de loi a une
conséquence claire et nette sans doute
la seule vider les caisses de la
Sécurité sociale à coup d'exonération de
cotisations parce que dans le texte de
loi le mot salaire n'apparaît presque
jamais je l'ai dit par contre le mot
exonération lui il est à presque tous
les paragraphes de ce projet de loi
alors vous nous faites comme si c'était
un cadeau fait aux salariés alors que
les cotisations sociales excusez moi
c'est du salaire du salaire socialisé
que vous leur enlevez
et que vous enlevez
que vous enlevez ou caisse de sécurité
sociale en supprimant donc les
cotisations petit à petit vous organisez
vous-même le déficit qui vous servira
plus tard à justifier la prochaine case
des retraites ou de l'assurance chômage
tout sauf les salaires et même si
possible tout est moins de salaire car
l'Insee a parfaitement montré les primes
se substitue au salaire plus exactement
30% des primes Macron ce sont substitués
au salaire et rien dans ce projet de loi
ne permet de contrer cela
laissons faire la concurrence entre les
travailleurs c'est le marché qui va
décider ce que vous proposez c'est la
plus pure idéologique néolibérale et ce
livre remarcher en fait vous arrange
bien une inflation record qui permet
d'énormes profits reversés aux
actionnaires et pas au salaire aux
salariés que vous avez considérablement
affaibli année après année grâce
notamment aux ordonnances Macron vive le
nécessaire pour évidemment les
actionnaires
tout sauf les salaires et dormez
tranquille actionnaires parce que et
bien va pouvoir se poursuivre cette
belle dynamique qui vous enrichit en
disant dans les entreprises du CAC 40 ce
fameux partage de la valeur à grignoter
énormément la part qui va vers le
travail et alors pour faire passer ça
vous nous sortez la démocratie sociale
alors là c'est vraiment la meilleure
vous osez tout et en fait c'est à ça
qu'on vous reconnaît
un gouvernement qui a fait passer en
force une grande réforme des retraites
contre la vie de tous les syndicats de
salariés qui a refusé tout compromis qui
restreint le droit de grève ce même
gouvernement vient nous parler
maintenant de démocratie sociale comme
si le gouvernement n'avait pas lui-même
strictement fixé le cadre de la corne
nationale interprofessionnel comme si
tous les syndicats de salariés avaient
signé cet accord comme si tous les
syndicats qui l'ont fait estimer
l'accord suffisant et bien non tous
disent tous les syndicats de salariés
que la priorité ce sont les augmentes
les augmentations de salaire et que ce
projet de loi est bien bien insuffisant
ils disent aussi qu'il faut un principe
et l'inscrire dans la loi qu'il faut
comme principe la non substitution au
salaire et ça et bien vous êtes bien
gardé de le transcrire dans le texte
alors que c'était dans l'accord
tout sauf les salaires voilà ce que nous
défendons avec les salariés en grève
pour leur salaire à IKEA à Disneyland
Paris au terme à Vichy à Lemercier en
joue à Angers et tant d'autres nous
sommes ici pour LCE pour ceux qui
produisent la valeur et qui envoient de
moins en moins la couleur voilà ce que
nous défendrons nous dans cette
hémicycle ne vous en déplace merci
madame la députée la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane Viry pour les
républicains et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission sur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues le dernier hacker national
interprofessionnel conclut en février
2023 entre les syndicats les
organisations patronales avaient pour
objectif de mieux associer les salariés
aux performances économiques des
entreprises et le projet de loi que nous
allons donc examiner dans quelques
minutes visent donc à transposer dans la
loi cet accord qui deviendrait de fait
opposable à toutes les entreprises la
droite républicaine a toujours
privilégié le dialogue social et je
voudrais à cet instant rappeler à
certains collègues peut-être l'article
premier du Code du travail qui impose
que tous les projets de loi envisagés
par le gouvernement qui porte sur les
relations individuelles ou collectives
du travail qui porte sur l'emploi ou qui
relève du champ de la négociation
nationale ou interprofessionnelle doit
faire l'objet d'une concertation
préalable avec les organisations
syndicales des salariés et des
employeurs
c'est donc bien la droite qui a pour
habitude de consulter les organisations
syndicales même lorsque celle-ci sont
opposées à un texte chers collègues le
gouvernement se drapent à beaucoup d'une
méthode s'appuyant sur le dialogue
social à travers ce projet de loi je
dois dire que ce n'est quand même pas le
principe voulu par le présent de la
République depuis 2017 personne n'osera
dire le contraire mais revenons à ce qui
nous concerne aujourd'hui c'est à dire
l'examen se projet de loi sur le fond
nous estimons chez les députés les
républicains que ce texte est utile car
il replace le débat entre le capital et
le travail c'est de concept ne doivent
pas être opposés mais plutôt converger
vers des solutions pérennes favorables à
tous il écarte du projet de loi se
faisant la lutte des classes réactivée
ou rechercher par certains et je dirais
même que ce projet de loi est contribue
à asseoir l'économie de marché et à
associer les salariés et les entreprises
dans la performance économique des
entreprises
et il est selon nous indispensable de
consolider l'économie de marché et
d'apporter tout autant des réponses
positives pour le pouvoir d'achat des
salariés comme je l'ai rappelé monsieur
le ministre lors de l'examen de ce texte
en commission des affaires sociales la
participation à l'intéressement des
salariés sur des idées gaullistes que je
souhaite ici rappeler et défendre la
participation permet de redistribuer aux
salariés une partie des bénéfices de
l'entreprise quand l'intéressement
permet d'associer financièrement les
salariés ou à la performance de
l'entreprise la corde nationale
interprofessionnelle de février permet
donc d'étendre l'éligibilité aux primes
d'intéressement et de participation aux
entreprises de plus de 11 salariés pour
rappel ce sont aujourd'hui 10 millions
de personnes qui bénéficient de ces deux
primes liées aux performances des
entreprises mais uniquement pour les
sociétés de plus de 50 salariés
la loi sur le partage de la valeur
propose d'abaisser le seuil à 11
salariés dans les petites entreprises
sous condition de rentabilité je l'avais
dit en commission et je le redis
aujourd'hui je vous ai je vous fais part
d'une réserve sur l'existence de ce
seuil qui exclut de fait les salariés
d'entreprise inférieures à 11 salariés
je maintiens cette réserve je ne suis
pas d'accord à ce que ces salariés de
petits entreprises partout de nos
territoires ne puissent pas bénéficier
d'un système permettant de partager le
bénéfice des entreprises
l'année prévoit également de revoir les
modalités d'application de la prime dite
de partage de la valeur cette prime
toujours exonérée d'impôt dans la limite
de 3000 euros par an pourra désormais
être versé deux fois dans l'année et
selon les partenaires sociaux ces
différents dispositifs devraient
permettre d'augmenter les revenus de 700
000 à 1 million de salariés et je
rappelle qu'en 2022 environ 30% des
entreprises françaises ont eu recours un
mécanisme de partage de la valeur
la prime de partage de la valeur a été
utilisée pour 86% des entreprises quand
seulement 19% d'entre elles ont eu un
recours à un dispositif d'intéressement
ou de participation bénéfices sans
conteste la prime de partage de la
valeur est le meilleur outil l'outil le
plus pertinent entre les mains des chefs
d'entreprise de petites entreprises pour
associer les salariés aux résultats de
l'entreprise le présent projet de loi
conformément à la corne national
interprofessionnelle aborde bien sûr
d'autres propositions la création pour
les entreprises de plus de 50 salariés
d'une obligation de négociation d'une
clause sur la prise en compte des
résultats exceptionnels la création d'un
plan de partage de la valorisation de
l'entreprise la mobilisation des
dispositifs d'épargne salariale est le
développement de l'actionnariat
salariale sur ces derniers points j'ai
encore des réserves je conserve d'abord
que l'actionnariat salarié et le parent
pauvre de ce projet de loi et que nous
aurions pu aller plus loin que ce qui
existe déjà sur l'épargne salariale son
affectation est un peu maigre et nous
aurions là aussi pu encore aller plus
loin les qui se font déjà beaucoup et
sur volontaires pour le faire et on
aurait pu afficher une ambition majeure
en la matière dès lors nous ne pouvons
être que favorables à ce projet de loi
transposant un ami sur certains sujets
effectivement nous aurions pu faire un
pas supplémentaire mais en toute
vraisemblance les députés du groupe les
républicains devraient voter ce texte
sous réserve des modifications qui
pourraient être opérées en séance merci
monsieur le député la parole est à
Madame Anne Bergans pour le groupe
démocrate et pour 5 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mesdames
et Messieurs mes chers collègues le
partage de la valeur est un facteur
essentiel d'attractivité des entreprises
de valorisation de justice sociale et de
cohésion sociale le 10 février dernier
après avoir mené des négociations de
plusieurs mois des négociations
difficiles mais constructives
l'intégralité des partenaires sociaux à
une exception près ont trouvé un accord
un accord poursuivant un but précis la
distribution plus juste des richesses
produites par les entreprises dans ce
contexte le Gouvernement a souhaité
aller plus loin sur le sujet en donnant
une assise législative à cette avancée
significative via le projet de loi
visant à transposer la corne nationale
interprofessionnelle sur la valeur sur
le partage de la valeur au sein de
l'entreprise ce projet de loi s'articule
donc autour de quatre objectifs
renforcer le dialogue social sur les
classifications faciliter la
généralisation des dispositifs de
partage de la valeur
la mise en place des dispositifs de
partage de la valeur et enfin développer
l'actionnariat salarié des notions
essentielles au principe de justice
sociale que vous savez chères aux
démocrates et que plusieurs lois visant
à simplifier et renforcer les
dispositifs de partage de la valeur dans
les entreprises sont venues conforter
ces dernières années bien que ce projet
de loi est précisément pour objet
d'assurer cohérence et fidélité aux
mesures convenues dans la nuit il
apparaît surprenant de constater la
volonté persistante des oppositions
d'éloigner le texte de sa focation
originelle et il est de même difficile
de comprendre la motivation qui
sous-entend cette démarche chers
collègues si nous procédons de la sorte
quel serait demain la valeur d'un accord
national interprofessionnel quel poids
aurait la parole d'une organisation
syndicale ou patronale s'ils savent que
le partement le Parlement peut
détricoter ce qu'ils ont négocié avec
leur père enfin quelle légit
aurions-nous à dévoyé et détourner de
son sens initial un accord ayant été
signé entre professionnels après
d'apprent négociation quand il s'agit
d'une transposition ce n'est pas là
notre rôle allez évident certains
amendements seraient susceptibles
d'altérer d'intégrité et l'esprit de ce
texte et remettrai en question
l'équilibre trouvé par les partenaires
sociaux à l'inverse je tiens à rappeler
ici que l'ensemble des amendements
portés par les démocrates ont fait
l'objet d'une négociation avec ces
derniers cet accord approuvé par
l'ensemble de l'arc républicain
représente un véritable compromis entre
les besoins des salariés et les défis
auxquels sont constamment confrontés des
employeurs et j'aimerais souligner ici
que si la CGT n'a pas signé l'accord
elle n'a jamais remis en question le
bien fondé de Lagny en appelant à voter
contre ce projet de loi
à l'inverse l'intitulé de certaines
oppositions reflètent bien une posture
idéologique qui sent le primer sur une
analyse approfondie et objective des
mesures contenues dans l'année certaines
de vos prises de position de parole en
commission traduisent une réflexion dont
je ne sais si elle tient de la
malhonnêteté ou de la méconnaissance de
ce qui est vraiment une entreprise une
entreprise elle se fonde initialement
sur une idée sur un projet sur des
Espérants le but premier de l'immense
majorité des chefs d'entreprise n'est
pas d'exploiter leurs salariés mais de
faire marcher leur entreprise de donner
une concrétule à leurs idées sans la
présence des employeurs
ignorez tout simplement pas
d'entreprises donc pas de salariés nul
l'entreprise ne saurait fonctionner sans
la présence et sans l'investissement des
salariés cela peut sembler candide mais
c'est une interdépendance bien plus
réelle et concrète que la vision
manichéenne que certains d'entre vous
souhaitent plaquer sur le monde du
travail l'accord transposé va bien
apprendre en considération
cet équilibre nécessaire et mettant
relief les vertus du dialogue social au
regard de l'importance fondamentale
qu'il revêt le groupe démocrate et
évidemment favorable à ce projet de loi
je vous remercie merci madame la députée
la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme Guedj
pour le groupe socialiste et apparenté
pour 5 minutes
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission monsieur le rapporteur
après la séquence disons le désastreuse
pour notre fonctionnement démocratique
et notre débat parlementaire de la
réforme des retraites la méthode avec
laquelle vous avez choisi d'aborder la
question cruciale du partage de la
valeur nous interpelle forcément
c'est vrai qu'après avoir fait la sourde
oreille pendant six mois 14 jours de
mobilisation interprofessionnelle
soutenue par l'unanimité des syndicats
de salariés on a un peu le sentiment que
le gouvernement veut se racheter à peu
de frais une vertu de parangon du
dialogue social
mais ce qui nous interpelle aussi c'est
que vous avez souhaité aborder la
question du partage de la valeur cela a
été dit par plusieurs de mes collègues
de mes collègues en la réduisant ou
strict champ de cet accord national
interprofessionnel dont je le redis vous
aviez vous-même limité le périmètre
d'intervention dans le document
d'orientation avec cette faute
originelle qui consiste à dire que pour
les partages de la valeur on évacue le
sujet central celui qui est au cœur des
préoccupations de nos concitoyens à
savoir la question des salaires quand
les Français vous parlent partagent de
la valeur il vous parle l'augmentation
des salaires il vous parle
revalorisation du SMIC et vous leur
répondez prime Macron actionnariat
salarié participation et intéressement
la deuxième sujet qui nous interpelle
évidemment
en respectant assurément la démocratie
sociale et la transposition d'un ami
c'est qu'on a le sentiment que vous
voulez limiter la démocratie
parlementaire par la démocratie sociale
et que ce faisant vous ne comprenez rien
ni à l'une ni à l'autre vous nous dites
les parlementaires doivent être les
gardiens de la cohérence de la parole
d'une gouvernement d'une certaine
manière donnée aux partenaires sociaux
vous nous dites que il faut transposer
tout Lagny rien que la nuit d'Ailleurs
d'abord on voit bien que les
négociations ont continué après le dépôt
du projet de loi et même entre la
Commission et la séance publique avant
avec la commission de suivi de la
transposition de l'ennemi par les
partenaires sociaux introduisant un
nouveau filtre si j'ose dire dans notre
fonctionnement parlementaire puisque
vous nous avez dit on n'acceptera on
admettra on mettra un avis favorable
uniquement sur ceux des amendements qui
ont reçu cette cette onction
pourtant la nuit n'est pas un bloc c'est
le produit d'une négociation et donc il
n'y a aucune raison pour qu'il n'y ait
pas un débat riche et fécond sur un tel
texte de la part de la représentation
nationale nous devons faire preuve d'une
vigilance particulière sur les effets de
chaque article le rôle des
parlementaires c'est d'analyser arctique
par article à Linéa par alinéa s'il y a
une avancée ou une régression notre
boussole c'est d'être le législateur de
100% des salariés garant de l'intérêt
général nous sommes tenus par une
exigence républicaine évidemment de
respecter la démocratie sociale mais
sans nous y soumettre
ce qui frappe aussi dans votre démarche
ce sont les manques et les paradoxes
le manque originel je l'ai déjà
mentionné c'est que vous manquez de
hauteur de vue dans l'ensemble des pays
du monde la part de la valeur ajoutée
distribuée aux salariés sous forme de
traitement de salaire ou de cotisation
sociale a baissé au cours des quatre
dernières décennies c'est une tendance
mondiale et la France n'est pas épargnée
en 80 73% de la valeur ajoutée aller au
salarié c'est tombé à 65% aujourd'hui
cette baisse elle s'explique
principalement par plusieurs causes les
politiques de modération salariale des
indexations des salaires sur sur
l'inflation dans laquelle vous vous
glissez dans laquelle vous vous
complaisez pourrai-je pourrais-je dire
c'est aussi la croissance des profits
non déclarés la financarisation de notre
économie et la place des acteurs
institutionnels dans le financement des
entreprises est aussi la gouvernance des
entreprises à laquelle vous ne vous
attaquez pas du tout qui donne davantage
de pouvoir aux actionnaires
c'est tout ceci qui nous manque
cruellement alors notre position est
très claire tout l'ANI oui mais pas rien
clany nous sommes favorables à ce que le
Parlement connaisse des textes issus de
la démocratie sociale et certaines des
propositions que nous avons avancées
s'inscrivent dans ce devoir de vigilance
que j'ai mentionné au début de notre
intervention de mon intervention mais
nous assumons quand même
d'aller plus loin et de proposer une
palette de solutions pour mieux partager
la valeur au sein de l'entreprise
c'était le sens des propositions sur la
revalorisation des salaires notamment
pour les plus petits salaires
l'augmentation du SMIC la convocation
d'une conférence nationale sur les
salaires l'instauration d'un ratio
d'écart salarial maximum dans les
entreprises revenir sur l'allègement de
fiscalité sur les actions gratuites
conditionner les biodégrations sociales
au respect d'indicateurs de partage de
la valeur ou des propositions par
exemple sur les sapeaux malheureusement
beaucoup d'entre elles ont été déclarés
irrecevables parce que votre choix de
texte de transposition ne nous le permet
pas alors je termine madame la
Présidente vous volez un débat sans
Annick roche pour faire adopter la nuit
vous risquez d'annuler le débat
parlementaire vous aurez quand même un
débat animé mais sans animosité
merci monsieur le député la discussion
générale et cl